[Music]
megan the stallion and dua lipa are
serving up some sweet sexy pie
just get ready
in their new music video for what else
sweetest pie
on friday the duo dropped their first
collab together
and let's just say
they nailed the assignment
[Music]
duo and meg play these spider queens in
an enchanted forest where they hold men
captive all the while serving some
serious couture a lot of body body adi
and crushing that choreo
[Music]
i mean megan could teach a master class
on the art of the twerk i did what i had
to do
and the 27 year old rapper opened up on
dua's new podcast dua lipa at your
service about how the whole song came to
be
i had wrote so many verses to this song
but finally like when i heard your voice
on it i was like no i need to rewrite
all of this this is not good enough
e.t caught up with the hot girl summer
rapper last month when she was fresh
from her graduation from texas southern
university and she teased that she has a
whole lot in store for her fans
including a performance at coachella you
know i like to surprise the hotties i
don't ever like to tell them too much um
i've definitely been like a little
absent on social media because i've been
getting my mind right i've been working
on my music so this year when i finally
do pop back out it's gonna be like
she was really working
yes
yes she was
in the long run i just wanted to show
everybody like if you put your mind on
something you can do it and while her
collab with dua is already a hit i'm so
excited meg told et she'd also like to
work with another mega star
a zeal girl call me you know this is
what the streets need they need that
collab and they need my choreography in
there too of course all this comes after
a mashup of adele's 2016 track water
under the bridge and megan's
choreography for body unexpectedly took
tick-tock by storm
[Music]
as for dua this time last year she took
home the grammy for pop vocal album what
did this night mean to you
just the absolute world you know to be
alongside so many of my peers so many
artists that inspire me to also see so
many incredible women picking up awards
making history to be a part of that was
just mind-blowing and to get an award
for my album future nostalgia is all i
could ever hope for it really really
means a lot to me so i'm just so happy
now she's busy on tour and launching a
fashion collection with puma so needless
to say these lady bosses are crushing
[Music]
i it take you home with us
[Music]